Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. It finally happened.
Marvel just announced that they're finally
starting the X-Men solo movie
that Kevin Feige teased
right after they bought Fox
and got the rights to all the characters
back.
That's how long it's been I'll explain
what's going on with the movie
and how it's going to be different from
the X-Men movies that have come before.
look.
They want to distinguish it from
the X-Men movies that have come before.
And there have been
some solid X-Men movies in the past.
and this is not to be confused
with any of the X-Men stuff
going on at Deadpool 3,
because there will be a lot of classic,
original X-Men Fox Marvel characters
coming back during that.
This movie, this new solo X-Men
movie, is a completely separate thing
with recast versions of the characters.
Hi. Hi.
How are you?
You have questions? Yes,
I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
so many questions.
I know everybody is wondering
what the hell is going on.
Deadpool Wolverine
trying to answer everything, giving away
all the spoilers for Kevin Feige.
just expect Deadpool
to spend a lot of time in that movie
clowning on them,
recasting all the X-Men characters.
In fact,
I think that's actually a core part of
the plot with him looking for
like the perfect version of Wolverine.
basically calling out Kevin Feige
for looking for the perfect actor
to recast as the new version of Wolverine
from Hugh Jackman
this part of the reason
why that movie is adapting.
Some of Deadpool kills
the Fox Marvel Universe
because everybody is getting recast
for the most part,
except for Deadpool himself.
Ryan Reynolds.
Don't worry, I'll explain everything.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We'll start hearing a lot more X-Men
related stuff.
When X-Men 97 Season one, Starz,
which is actually going to be in early
2024,
I will be doing episode videos for that
and we do have Loki season
two episodes also starting this week,
which I'll be doing videos for
but most of you
probably saw the news
in your feeds this week
because the writers strike ended
Hallelujah.
Marvel can finally start hiring writers
to actually start working on the new solo
X-Men movie.
While the strike was going on,
they literally had to stop working
on all their brand new projects.
Now most of you will ask
why it's taken 84 years for them
to do a solo X-Men movie since they got
the rights back to all the characters
back in 2019, around the time Avengers
Endgame was coming out
in theaters for the most part,
Marvel phase for Marvel.
Phase five.
Like everything
since Avengers, Endgame
has been pretty chaotic
with the Marvel movies,
the Disney Plus shows.
it's been very polarizing in the way
that I think of Marvel Phase four phase,
like everything up to phase
six is the phases When Marvel had not done
new versions of X-Men or Fantastic
Four characters.
Yeah, like the phases where we waited for
the new X-Men to show up.
Basically Marvel's
been benching its biggest,
historically, most popular characters
since they got the rights back in.
For instance, a lot of their best
female characters are X-Men characters.
we've gotten a few X-Men and Fantastic
four cameos, scenes in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness
with Patrick Stewart,
Professor X and John Krasinski,
Reed Richards.
But that's about it.
Like,
that's barely a teaser The funny way.
Robert Downey
Jr talked about what's going on
since Avengers Endgame
when he was asked about coming back
as Iron Man was saying that Marvel
was quote unquote, on a journey
I also think that Marvel
is on this journey now of they're trying
a bunch of other stuff and it lets,
you know, I'm excited for them
to see how all that goes and it's hard
to it's hard to project, now.
There are so many rumors still out.
The fan theories.
People want to see Iron Man come back.
Could it ever happen?
Yeah. Anything could happen.
I'm really enjoying.
and all these wonderful things.
I'm looking right down the barrel.
what that meant is that Marvel would just
trying out a bunch of weird stuff
because typically they have to work about
five years out, like that's how long
it takes to develop and get movies going
and actually release them.
So for example, The Eternals were meant
to be the replacement for the X-Men
because when they developed the movie,
it was about five years out
and they didn't know that they would get
the X-Men characters back.
So they did kind of like a replacement,
like some brand new huge group.
So there were a lot of Eternals plans
that they had early on before Avengers
Endgame came out.
as we saw, things did not work out
with that the way they expected.
But they also got all the Marvel
characters back,
meaning that they could do X-Men
so they didn't need to rely on Eternals
or bunch of the other
weird characters or no.
I love all those weird characters.
Like I will do Marvel videos
til I'm blue in the face.
Like I'll be 84 years old
with like 3 different editors
that need to help me
just to get videos out on a regular basis.
but the real grade-A stuff, Kevin Vega
has been sitting on this whole time
like general audiences are really looking
for, or X-Men, Fantastic Four stuff.
I'm super hyped about that new Fantastic
Four movie.
I've already seen
a couple of videos about it,
and there are a couple of reasons
why Kevin five wanted to do that.
First, before X-Men, because X-Men itself
has been much more popular historically
than the Fantastic Four.
like,
there are way more original X-Men movies
that are still solid today
compared to Fantastic Four movies,
Marvel had a way longer to go
to revitalize the fantastic Four brand,
and they debuted first in the comics way
before the X-Men.
So that was Kevin Fight,
his reasoning for doing that first.
also there were
some weird contractual issues
when they got the characters back,
preventing them from recasting
a lot of the X-Men characters
like 2024 or 2025,
but now that basically over,
they can do whatever they want.
right now, the new X-Men
movie isn't supposed to be released
till late 2026 2027.
Marvel
just delayed everything by a few months,
so do not be surprised
if the release date changes a little bit.
It's still very early days Right now
they're taking pitches for the new movie
and it's usually about a 2 to 3 year
turnaround once they have the writers.
Now the new X-Men solo
movie will mostly feature a totally new
cast of actors
playing all the core characters.
So we're talking about big recast here
what they'll do for, like Hugh Jackman's
version of Wolverine,
a lot of the classic actors
is still use the multiverse twist to say
that they exist in another universe,
like those classic Fox Marvel movies or
CONAN through the multiverse, technically,
because they will fix a couple of things
during secret wars,
even though they're collapsing
the multiverse.
Ryan Reynolds will survive to continue
as Deadpool
in upcoming Marvel movies
after Deadpool 3 maximum effort.
but generally Marvel Phase
seven Everything after Secret Wars
is meant to be the beginning
of a more X-Men focused saga
with all brand new versions
of the characters,
like the beginning of True line
wide crossovers, you always dream
they should have been doing
this whole time
with all the characters
crossing over like it's no big deal.
Spider-Man interacting with Wolverine,
the Fantastic Four, The Avengers, meaning
the X-Men and movies who's from Marvel,
who works with all the other studios.
He works with Sony and Fox.
That's his job in the eyes. I said, Man,
can this happen?
And he goes, Look, it's
not going to be easy
because you're working
with different studios
and have their properties that I believe.
Maybe I'm optimistic.
I understand Marvel.
They've got Avengers,
they've got a lot of big things going on,
but at some point I just find it
almost impossible.
There's not a way to bring.
Imagine all the Avengers characters,
you know, Wolverine,
the X-Men characters, Spider-Man,
and somehow get them in together.
but I'm in for it.
I'm totally off rule
because I think that would be
really exciting for fans across the board.
Hugh Jackman even called this Babe
Ruth style way, way back in the day
in the guy that he talks about who was
telling him about this was Kevin Bogey.
things that previously armies of lawyers
prevented from happening.
And also,
if you remember, Kevin Vega actually
got his start producing in movies,
working on Marvel movies during that first
Bryan Singer X-Men 2000 movie.
This is baby Kevin Vega,
basically sitting in the back of the room,
not being allowed to talk
because he was so low in the totem pole.
Hugh Jackman even says that Kevin Feige
on the set of that movie would sneak him
Wolverine comics because he didn't know
anything about the character.
And Bryan Singer
apparently had banned comic books on set.
you had a picture, a 20
something Kevin Feige,
like running around
with armloads of comic books,
sneaking them
to all the actors on the set.
you might remember that he actually tried
to get the X-Men Spider-Man
in that first Avengers movie
when Marvel Phase one launched,
but he just couldn't make it happen
because of legal reasons.
This is the original Iron Man
Post-Credits scene.
Setting that up,
right
now, it looks like Marvel is going to try
and pull a first class
kind of twist with this new version.
The X-Men characters were the new recast
versions are much younger just in general,
so that it's easier to do more movies
with them before the actors are aging out.
And that becomes a big issue.
so expect a mixture of teenage 2030
something actors.
Some of the new versions like Magneto,
Professor X want to be a little bit
older, obviously, but most of them
can still be in their twenties.
one of the other biggest new changes,
though, with this new solo X-Men movie
is that Kamala Khan, Ms..
Marvel will probably crossover
or at least have a cameo seen
because they just canonized her in the MCU
as a mutant.
they also just made that change
in Marvel Comics as well, too.
That's why they played the theme song
from X-Men Animated Series during the Ms..
Marvel series.
Speaking of X-Men, the Animated series,
I know there's tons of questions
about X-Men 97, Season one episodes
they're supposed to release in early 2024.
Don't worry, we'll get more trailers
for that later this year.
I've already done
a couple of trailer videos
for the footage that they have released,
so I'll put those links
in the description below.
But you probably notice
the Easter eggs in the background.
The upcoming movies.
Marvel's been slowly setting up these new
versions of the X-Men characters already.
there's going to be a big adamantium
subplot in Captain America four.
They're going to say that
adamantium in the MCU comes from
that dead celestial body from the Eternals
movie.
Adamantium is the path to the new Weapon
X program,
the new version of Wolverine in the MCU.
Val is supposed to be behind that.
The weapons
plus program should also probably be
behind the new Sentinels program
to The other big reason
why Kevin Feige has waited
so long to do that solo X-Men movie
and recast the characters
is they plan to use Deadpool
3 in Avengers
six Secret Wars is the last
two big swan songs
for the classic versions of the characters
from the Fox Marvel movies
like Kevin Fire.
He wanted to give those characters
their own version of Avengers Endgame.
In that will be Secret Wars.
The minor difference with Deadpool
3 is that it's mostly
just the original X-Men characters
coming back in that the first class
X-Men characters
will probably cameo during Secret Wars.
so because they got all their characters
back for the most part,
like Spider-Man is still kind
of a weird issue, sharing it with Sony.
But for the most part they have all this
preexisting baggage and continuity.
All of these previous movies
they deal with.
The easiest way for Kevin Feige
to deal with that is obviously for him
to just soft reboot everything, retune it
so that it's all happening
in the same universe.
not like a hard reboot, just like retuning
things just a little bit.
So that all makes sense in his way.
Simpler for casual audiences starting
in Marvel Phase seven Going forward.
just the way to explain
why all these characters from the comics
all exist on the same planet.
what might wind up happening
is they just wait to do that
new solo X-Men
movie till like right after Secret Wars,
like X-Men will either be the first movie
in Marvel, Phase seven, or the Pool
like a Spider-Man far from Home,
where they have an Epilog movie
right after their big Avengers movie.
Then the real Marvel Phase seven begins.
But my early theory right now
is that Marvel will treat the next saga
after Secret Wars as the mutant saga
eventually building up to
like their new version of a much,
much bigger version of the Phenix saga.
Let me know in the comments.
Besides what's happening in Deadpool 3
with like
the classic versions coming back,
which brand new versions of characters
do you want to see pop up in the MCU
before that solo X-Men movie happens?
big reminder though.
My Fool Loki Season 2 Episode
one Video will post Friday.
My Ahsoka
finale video will also post this week.
Click here for that onto the link as soon
as I post it and click here for that.
Loki vs Frog Thor Deleted scene video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!